a yura marina pttu arsenal imagenet
ابن مقرض وسوف بجانبي
ترى العالم ملفات وسائل الإعلام الروسية من الأرض نعم
هنا هي عالية في الحرارة Ai love to let on
دولار أو من
[موسيقى]
كل ذلك أثناء المشي
كم هو مخيف
مخيف
اليوم
انطلق حمص تورسونوف هاي ألت من دفة القيادة
اسم كلا المترين هو نفسه يمنحهم كل منهما
الجيران اليوم يقولون مرحبا وعادوا بالفعل
لا نساعد دائمًا شيئًا نحضره هنا
نحضر وبالفعل
خذ خمسة
قدم مع الله أو تعرف كيف تحفر ناتاليا
كنت اتوقع انك
كيف يمكن للناس
يقلى الأطفال
[موسيقى]
أبي قاتل المدافع عن ستالينجراد
كنت أعتقد أن بوتين سيفعل ذلك
خاركيف كاتالينا سعيد للقضية
حتى الحيوان لن يفعل ذلك
نذل
سوف أقوم بتدريس العام الذي كانت فيه الموسم الأول
Akuma بدون إيمان ثم رمز آخر هو طبقات و
أنف
إلى الأوروبيين canin mintop و dharm home
سعيد وانا
كانت حياة سلمية لم تكن في المنزل ليوم واحد ومن
لا يوجد
لم يفاجأ أي روسي
نفسه روسي باللغتين الروسية والأوكرانية و
أتحدث أقل وكان كل شيء على ما يرام
وهكذا ذهب
حصلنا
تعمل كفاءتها في صندوق من قطعة واحدة
لمدة 40 عامًا و zapata ولكن فقط عن الفندق
الوضع الآمن
هذا هو غضب تايهيونغ
[موسيقى]
كان هذا منزلي
قبل الحرب ، هكذا ، هذا كل شيء و
يبقى منزلي حتى في هذا
قادر
لن أذهب إلى أي مكان
هذه بلدي
صفر بدوره على الضجيج في ملحمة
هؤلاء هم الوافدون
[موسيقى]
سباق ميشال كورت
الرجال ليسوا على ما يرام
على وجه نبيل ميوما عاهرات خاركيف تيرا
كولمار ، ثم ظهر الرب للعجول
الميل هو أمبروموفا أريد أن أكون في المنزل
لم أحصل عليه بصعوبة كبيرة ، لقد حصلت على هذا
شقة بصعوبة كبيرة
سعيد لأنني أملكها ولست أنا
لا أريد الذهاب إلى أي مكان لا أريد الذهاب إلى أي مكان
[موسيقى]
هذا الجانب
إلا أنا
سأضغط من والميداليات للفيلم نعم نعم
المذنبات على موقع الراديو في هتافات دقيقة واحدة
فيدورا أنا لو مارينا